bonjour toujours un sur des dalles tv
l'actualité internationale championnat
du monde et toujours avec laurent
frayssinet laurent fait sienne vice
champion de france
donc cette année donc on avait parlé sur
cette émission aux précédentes donc
perdu le titre face à quatre chefs mais
à égalité avec une perf à 2007
et tu vas pas tu vas passer à prendre ça
c'est une nouvelle dans les 50 premiers
mondiaux un peu près dix ans que j'ai un
héros aux alentours de 1650 de 1650 à
peu près de 50
donc c'est un joli bond quand même parce
que cg oui tu dois être 80e à peu près
là c'est sa riche et ça je gagne un peu
plus de 20 points d'accord c'est bien et
tu penses que tu peux arriver au dos là
où et comment j'espère même si j'ai 24
ans donc j'espère que je répondrais
d'accord mais ce que comment tu vois ta
marge de progression on fait ce que
c'est vraiment tu te sens tu te sens
capable d'arriver là est ce que tu as
envie
est ce que est ce que tu sais ce qu'il
faut faire encore joué par exemple au
championnat de france gt une perf à 2700
manger bien joué mais bon je pense que
je peux jouer assez régulièrement comme
ça donc évidemment quand on fait des
perfs à 2700 sa possible nello d'accord
dans ses alentours mais mais est ce que
tu es ce que tu vois ce que tu perçois
ce que tu devrais faire pour y arriver
il faudra veiller tout ça peut faut
travailler parce que je n'aime pas c'est
n'importe quel travail en fait qu'on
trahit les finales les ouvertures ou les
milieux de tous tout ça est simplement
le contact passait les échecs le plus on
fait le mieux c'est et ça c'est premier
sera pas aussi une stratégie pour gagner
des points elo c'est à dire de jouer ne
pas jouer par exemple eu trop de peine
parce que les autres on voit que c'est
lui sont plus risqués - oui mais bon il
faut bien aussi gagner sa vie
quelques plaies d'accord parce que moi
je me rappelle de kasparov
dans les années 80 qui lorsqu'il voulait
battre le fameux record 2000 2800 points
elo
avait enchaîné avait avait avait mis en
place une stratégie on le voit dans son
île avait créé dans un livre je ne sais
plus lequel il avait mis en place une
stratégie pour pouvoir arriver à cet
objectif et jouer un certain nombre de
tournois qu'il avait planifié et pour
lui qui s'était préparé spécifiquement
avec l'objectif de passer de 1800 et
loup alors quoi donc
et là il a réussi alors voilà alors très
flatteur pour moi que tu me comprends
l'agacement
mais alors dans la dépendamment de
kasparov mais disons que d'un simple moi
je suis paquet sport a fait donc je peux
pas déjà choisi en béton c'est à dire
que les dieux quand on met vite bon je
suis déjà assez content qu'on ma vie
dans ce tournoi avec des bons joueurs et
je sers arles et on a fermé il ya de
moins en moins de temps à fermer pour de
plus en plus de former de bons joueurs
donc c'est très rare les tours à faire
mais bon malheureusement je suis enfin
malheureusement j'aime bien les open je
obligé de jouer les open et l'état de
forme mais c'est possible de venez
d'arriver à 2700 vendée open il ya
beaucoup de joueurs beaucoup d'exemples
d'accord mais bon de toute façon je joue
par équipe principalement nous avons
beaucoup de championnats différents avec
l'équipe de france
donc je joue beaucoup de chanteurs
apéritif et beaucoup de temps à fermer
alors tu te sentirais capable d'arriver
à quel niveau et loup je pense que 2700
c'est un très bon objectif et je pense
que je qu'elles peuvent y arriver
bon c'est en tout cas ça serait une
bonne nouvelle pour les chaînes
françaises en aurait deux ont ils
tiennent et ils auront donc c'est
pourquoi pendant les deux font la paire
comme dit l'autre parce qu est ce que tu
sens qu etienne lacroix plus de
capacités que toi ou est-ce qu'il a eu
plus de moyens ou est ce que est ce que
tu es ce que tu le sens est ce que tu te
sens capable de séparer les capacités je
sais que le jour d'aujourd'hui ce
émergentes mois avant voilà j'aime mieux
que moi
bon après c'est pas un truc irréversible
la creuse toujours confiant que chargé
je peux faire des progrès je travaille
pour je travaille beaucoup plus
maintenant qu'avant donc
l'entraîneur vauréen trailer particulier
où tu t'entraînes tout seul non disons
que j'étais au début de l'année par
exemple je suis allé à wisches lundi
j'étais ce moment d'yvan ce colloque oui
et
avant on avait fait une session à paris
pendant deux semaines je suis allé chez
lui de 10 jours avant j'ai passé à moi
là bas à gauche candidat ou scanzano
pratiquement un mois ces interminables
d'ailleurs encore toi cependant ce n'est
pas facile parce que surtout que ça pas
très bien marché pour les donc cette
collaboration et c'est vrai que c'est
pas facile de trouver serré qu'à paris
avant je jouais je m'entraîne beaucoup
et joël lautier
mais maintenant il serait plutôt c'était
un peu moins aux échecs oui plus de
choses à couvrir plus de choses à côté
et plus trop joueur est donc bon il
taclé - joueur il est toujours un jeu
vous toujours délicat il veut plus
entraîné voilà il le dit ouvertement
mais c'est qu'ils entraînent de plus
voilà voilà donc évidemment que c'est un
des piliers des kim de france évidemment
c'est un très bon jeu avec cette
expérience il a tellement travaillé
avant mais bon donc ça fait que
l'appareil maintenant c'est délicat avec
vraiment quelqu'un de mon niveau qui
veut travailler ça existe pratiquement
pas oui c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est
pas simple il faut trouver des
collaborateurs du coup il faut trouver
des collaborateurs qui qu'il faut si en
plus tu peux pas les payer plus j'ai pas
les moyens c'est à dire qu'un grand
maître doit trouver c'est mon propre
maître en voyant tout cas quelqu'un qui
veut travailler qui à peu près même
niveau avec un kit 2004 mais de notre
côté on a vu kasparov avec des
entraîneurs moins fort que lui forcément
oui mais pas beaucoup moins fort que lui
ce projet trouve un grand maître au
moins grands maîtres cas des 1500 voilà
c'est ça et qui qui correspondent à ton
style ou est ce que tu veux mais à ton
style et qui veut travailler il faut
vouloir travailler ça peut se trouver
alors on va revenir évidemment sur ce
championnat du monde
quatrième partie entre kramnik et
topalov alors le match est de plus en
plus bouillant d'ailleurs et on va en
parler
vantard l'été et topalov s'est brûlé
mais mais il se passe des choses aussi
on va voir après qu après cette
quatrième partie s'est passé des choses
et que et que ça commence même à
dépasser le cadre chic tiens on va voir
on va voir ça on va en parler mais
d'abord on va quand même voir ces jeux
c'est parti en parlant de ça moi ça me
ce qui m'a surpris c'est les premières
images des listes un ou les deux joueurs
sont arrivés ensemble était tout sourire
si c'est parce qu'il avait vu les photos
mouais c'est même joué une partie blitz
oui enfin c'était ça tu le sais c'était
protocolaire c'était protocolaire mais
ce que kasparov et karpov pourrait jouer
une partie de la veille ou que trois
jours avant le drame alors pas fait
c'est un truc j'ai trouvé ça bizarre et
maintenant je préfère ça en fait je
préfère que les chaudières on a envie
que les deux joueurs se laissent pas
forcément qu'ils soient urbains avec eux
que ce qui est un vrai qu'un vrai combat
voilà qui incombe à le faire c'est
l'ambiance qui est vrai combat pas qu'il
fasse des beats ensemble qui souhaitent
tout sourire pâtisserie c'est évidemment
oui bien sûr mais en tout cas qui est un
vrai combat oui voilà qu'une vraie
distance est en tout cas c'est un train
de qui ait pas de conflit d'intérêts
disons qu'entre entre l'amitié peut-être
dès que le match amical et qu il avait
le même manager c'était un peu plus un
peu tendance un peu limite quoi mais sur
ibiza
alors on va voir cette partie quatrième
très importante pour topalov qu'elle est
blanc qui quand ils menaient 2 0 après
avoir tenté de gagner
les deux premières et il commence cette
partie par des quatre donc c'est le coup
du match pour l'instant en vidéo je
pense qu'il jouera peut-être comme j'ai
dit à l'émission d'avant il est il
évitera la pétrole jusqu'au bout est-ce
que kramnik lui peut jouer qu'à je pense
pas non plus sauf si vraiment je pense
qu'ils avaient prévu de jouer quatre
fois c'est juste une supposition si le
match tournait manière de jouer il va
beaucoup plus agressif si le match
tournait mal bon a priori touché le plus
catalan il essaie de jouer rien sans
risque où il ya des petites chances de
bien comme on l'a vu d'un troisième
partie quand même il a raté des bonnes
occasions mais de très grosses occasions
lors qu'il n'ya pas un frein de risque
alors oui il a jamais risqué de faire
donc pour lui c'est la sécurité c'est un
peu à l'image du match qu'il a fait
contre eux caspar au final c'est un fait
pour l'instant c'est ça prend 7,7 en
rien sa pensée de tomber alors allez
peut-être un topalov qui prend encore
plus de risques que kasparov et donc du
coup ça se retourne contre lui alors
donc décaler cette faute donc des 5
donc ça c'est mais c'est la répétition
la deuxième c'est un peu surprenante qui
choisissent haslam donc pourquoi pas
alors on fait plaisir que j'ai vraiment
un adepte
donc c'est en ouverture donc ça te donne
des armes nouvelles
oui mais ça ne doit aussi du travail du
coup oui parce que tu es mon analyse ça
alors voilà c'est la classe lave donc
qui est 4 caractérisée par ce coup ici
donc c'est donc on a un début du conte
dame un classique et la secoue
caractérise la cela s'est très
logiquement kostek on conteste le
sentent simplement voilà on protège le
centre et à la différence du gambit
dames où on ne protège plus tôt par six
on bouge pas la diagonale du fou on peut
sortir soit en fait un soir j'ai 4 donc
c'est la grande différence entre les
deux ces matières est aussi bon en joie
aussi sont à l'idée de jouer ces cinq
ans fait alors que là c'est pas l'idée
l'idée c'est d'obtenir la casse des
scènes alors on continue
logique car les c3 on augmente la
pression son personnel au point ces
pièces qu'alexis logique aussi on
développe et là le premier changement
alors voilà premier changement donc là
ici à trois qui qui boucherait sortie du
fou donc ça c'est un début je crois que
yann jeu s'appelle pas le début cole ou
un truc comme ça non enfin qu'il est
bacon 1 c'est le foie avancé pas ça et
on ne met pas le prénom c'est rien avoir
oublié ce que c'est on rentre dans une
famille slave en se musclant la slave
c'est ce qu'ils avaient joué à la
première à la deuxième partie
oui c'est à dire à peu près en bouche
l'eau s'ils le peuvent agir par et b
ambulant non on muscle fous pour
protéger le perron d'un c4 haye pour
protéger avec le fauve à sa gauche
foulée ça évite les prises ici avec
l'esa les garder loin on peut rappeler
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé d'un
deuxième partie cavaliers f3 oui suivi
puis on prend ces quatre mois puis on
pensait qu'à travers un dessin qui suit
voilà la cia fait la cad donc et voilà
ces deux suisses avaient été empêchés
par un cadre mais voilà l'idée donc en
fait il faudra pour empêcher
il fait 3 donc du coup pour reprendre
tout de suite éventuelle alliance option
avec le food en cas de prise et donc
éviter ces variantes ou les noirs
s'accroche aux pions éventuellement
maintenant le foot cannois en général il
se développe soit en d2 soit on joue b3
à b2 voilà ce fou mais il va avoir du
mal à sortir du coup c'est là qu'on ne
peut pas avoir tout va pas avoir le
beurre l'argent du beurre ils exactement
la première l'afflux de la crémière
cambio train etc etc bref alors le 6 mai
en bouche aussi ils font donc en bouche
on fout ça aussi c'est un lacet non
c'est pas bien parce que sur france 5
alors imaginons sur vous faut être
simple logique les blancs jouer dame b 3
à terre voilà de b3 à chalon sur le pion
mais cette attaque attaque des 5 atteint
c'est trop c'est trop et on peut pas
protéger 17 mais si tu protèges par
exemple et rejoint des six décision va
prendre en d5 leur comprendre
ouais dans ce cas là on prend les temps
comprend foulée cinq échecs et la voilà
mon problème en profite du fait que les
cases blanches ont été désertés koala et
il ya le clan des seins qui tombent
il se trouve que on est obligé de mettre
quelque chose dans 17 villes au giro de
fait le fou par exemple pour elle
qu'elle allait prendre les gens pour des
c
ça fait tout de suite ont permis aux
hawks et rapide donc il faut pas que
c'est très connu évidence un trick de
joueurs d'accord impuissant sur ce coup
là on n'est pas du tout parce que je
joue pas du tout cette ouverture là donc
je suis hors au bout or books out of
preparation les inquiète pas c'est
vraiment découvre tram ni d'ailleurs à
l'époque et à peut-être une dizaine
d'années c'est l'ouverture principales à
cela donc c'est une demi surprise de
voir
d'accord aussi ce que les trois l'anc
logique alors cavailles f3 seul cas les
bd c'est qu'on voit c'est très logique
aussi et la mode la mode c'est plutôt de
jouer à 6 aux jo qui avait 17 ans ont
voulu tout sur blanc avec l'idée de
jouer 5 ou c5 en fête ou c5 pour
empêcher justement des fouilles des sacs
à main pour lévis pour éviter les échecs
ici est derrière un petit coup
d'attentes otages ici la case les cinq
ans on attend de voir ce que ce que les
blancs font donc une autre variante
rêvée de se l'être mais ce hacker 17
c'est très logique donc c'est logique on
développe un cavalier bon mais vu que la
quasi s'y est prise dans la case naturel
c'est celle ci ou des trois lacs en rien
donc ça c'est logique il a poussé même
ces deux jolies passes pour le fou donc
eu d'eau est hors de question ça sert à
rien puisque toute façon y'a pas fou g4
le fouet prononcée là bas donc ici c'est
toujours la meilleure quasi pour le fond
staff ayant pris part aux quatre ans
prépare aussi aux 4 c'est logique quand
on prend ses quartiers le bon moment en
bois là il faut il vaut mieux prendre
c'est votre lebouleux fois bouger c'est
pour ça qu'on vous aime c'est des fois
pour retarder
ah ouais m'enfin ça c'est intéressant
ces deux variantes moment c'est pas dit
qu'on soit jamais probablement quelle
amère b5 tribu j'adore le foot et le fou
veut se développer en b cet essai on va
mettre le fou ici voilà c'est ça et
après on peut jouer à 6 et 7 6 5
d'accord libéral fou et pourtant quand
il s'essaye d'une épaisseur attaque
licences etc
donc voilà l'idée donc la foux dutronc
revient logique foulée 7
donc là c'est bien s'il est noir il va
jouer à six et cinq à six essais 5
c'est terminé pour eux c'est très bien
c'est parfait il en aurait au moins
égaliser voire même plus les avantages
d'un certificat plus ils en c1
et un grand carrefour ici les blancs
peuvent jouer soit petit rock soit e4 au
4t logique ont amené ça soit le coût de
la partie alors le coût de la partie on
va le voir tout de suite c'est à 3 alors
qu'ils alors bizarre petit con bien fait
qui est logique en cadeau à 6 tout
simplement doublé 400 niveaux là où
quelle façon en cas de n'importe quel
autre coup qui empêche pas a déclaré
joubert dont je vais car il m'en fous
sera missionné pour verrouiller stockage
et empêcher a jamais de soccer ne
bougeait bougera plus en plus jamais ou
alors voilà c'est un sacrifice coiffer
une belle ouverture donc c'est très très
connu tout ce qui pousse tant d'arts on
peut l'empêcher par à cinq et on
abandonne l'idée de jouer ces cinq
puisque l'avion là bas sera faible donc
voilà on peut pas tout avoir le beurre
l'argent du beurre premières etc alors
des quatre attaques
le cavalier et surtout empêche et
empêche les mêlant de fait empêche les
domaines du fer rouge éclate donc ses
classiques c'est connu ça c'est très
connu mais cam et riou 4 on parle aussi
avec 470 cas donc il a choisi télé ou 4
donc on est toujours là théorie tout à
fait cavaler prend fou prend maintenant
pions prend à 3 non mais normal aussi
voilà donc peu alors petit problème pour
les noirs c'est supions qui est un peu
arriérés quand même une gamme plus
bloquée il un peu sous la pression du
fou mais bon d'un autre côté on se dit
que si le casier bien là il faudra
qu'ils bougent se fout et m'ont
peut-être on va jouer ces cinq très vite
tu sais pas on va voir dans que peut
tirer un petit rôle et on prend pas le
pion et on reprend pas le public de
topalov donc il veut reprendre du fou
mais il veut se développer il était un
peu sonné doivent attaquer c'est en fait
c'est normal c'est évident c'est typique
c'est typique mais si tous ces péchés
ouais c'est connu et c'est pas bon de
prendre de plus en séparant bien trop de
jeu m aux jo d'accord donc il faut
absolument jouer ce qu'a joué crânement
c'est à dire une déliquescence voilà il
faut pas surtout pas perdre de pierre de
temps à prendre un pion qui permet de
développer la dernière pièce et puis on
ça va être une attaque
- christian roy est de fous
potentiellement braqués sur le roi et
donc il ya beaucoup de jeunes cavaliers
qui peut peut-être vont dire plus tard
c'est pas la dame qui va pas tarder à se
mettre par exemple ces deux bombes ont
fait ça fait exactement ça fait beaucoup
de bien ça fait beaucoup de jeu c'est
vrai beaucoup de possibilités sans
compter que les colonnes et en toutes
couvertes aussi il peut y avoir des
pièces qui traîne derrière enfin bon
faut faire attention
et là il joue bien on voit b3 la
principale idée c'est que s'il prend 1,3
au lieu de fermer trois alors s'y prend
1,3 simplement le procès ne sera pas
faible tandis que là comme on va le voir
inception n'est pas faible des trois
salers la colonne semi ouverte
alors donc en 4 baies 3 avril à prendre
le pion il va apprendre à connaître et
du full est derrière ce pion peut être
actée par la tour inception sera fait
donc il faut gagner du jeu dans le côté
aussi casse autant il casse son maximum
la symétrie c'est à dire qu'on va
vraiment dans une position totalement
asymétrique
on peut voir que les chaînes de piolenc
rien à voir il ya un pion de plus ici
control pions là et du coup un pion sur
bacon 30 pions sur a2 manque les chaînes
de pions sont pas symétriques ça
augmente les chances de résultats à dire
un alors qu'à ya six ans c'est ce que
j'ai dit à leur bon ça c'est pour
enlever ce fou qui est quand même gênant
ouvrons suppression d'aidés le faut à
partir de ces cinq et on veut jouer ces
scènes très vite on veut libérer le fou
donc c'est logique donc le foot attaquer
donc ya pas trop le choix il faut soit
le défendre sur l'enlever et donc il
choisit de le défendre donc il est prêt
à donner la paire de fou mais il est
même prendrait plus que ça c'est un
mêmes ce que ça
ah ouais tout à fait ah oui oui bien sûr
il ya la fameuse attaque possible
oui peut-être fou prend échec et ensuite
on regarde et on regarde on vous prend
et cavaliers prendre aux quatre coins du
canada
il peut y avoir ou car il prend le cadre
d'un programme séparé d'accord et oui et
après il y aura il y aura un échec ici
et on pourra apprendre et relayer un
truc très malin de topalov alors on va
regarder qui prend calais prend donc
dans ce cas là qu'elle allait prendre 4
ou prince de fourrage deux ans prend on
va prendre force et si on prend pas il
ya tout de suite derrière damage quatre
essais ça c'est énorme
il faut jamais faut toujours prendre
c'est dans ces attaques la soie sa
terrain voilà c'est très rare qu'on
puisse se permettre de ne pas prendre
parce que derrière l'attaqué encore plus
forte
c'est une fausse idée ne pas prendre et
la démarche 4 damas quatre échecs
logique en j 1 donc là y'a pas le choix
le roi est obligé de mener en gnc lequel
est maintenant on reprend la pièce est
fou prend 1,3 ici et maintenant vous
prend à 30 par an pendant 20 ans et à 3
d'abord d'abord f3 pour profiter que le
fou continue de protéger ma passion ici
exactement donc la dame est obligé de
jouer par exemple en d5 voilà et mène un
fou pour un troyen peu plus rock'n'roll
et c'est connu quand il est fou de
colère en pause et c'est le nombre de
pions ne compte pas mais c'est ce que
qualitatif oui c'est ça qui est
l'initiative folle attaque parce que ta
couleur opposée c'est par ce fou contre
les cases blanches sous foulée casement
donc ils sont complètement de nos
concurrents et donc c'est celui qui
prend l'initiative l'attaqué
l'occurrence là c'est les blancs qui
empêche le rock le petit rock en tout
cas bon de retrait et empêcheur le rock
cette tour est hors jeu cette tour est
en jeu et le roi et mais il est pas
super labrune grand hockey autrement et
leurs grands qu'eux
tu es ouvert il ya une colonne ouverte
ici il y en a une autre
ici ça fait beaucoup là ça fait beaucoup
ce pion peuvent aussi servir de bélier
éventuellement non ça fait beaucoup trop
donc très belle variante où on
al'impression effectivement que les
noirs gagne et même y gagne un pion mais
au final ils ont plus le rock et ils
vont ce faire ils vont se faire
massacrer quoi voilà exactement se faire
massacrer au qu'évidemment kramnik évite
tout ça donc sur calais d2 il fait
passer deux variantes qu'à l'ére bonne
mais il joue tout simplement dams et 7
il est balèze travnik on lui on lui fait
passer un vieux briscard c'est un vieux
loup dont il met la dame ici et il me
lance maintenant un message 2 et il sait
un vrai faux proche de tranquillou
ensuite je ramène le faux la maison oui
et il veut c 5 aussi élevé ses cinq
doubles violence et le double coup donné
le fou tout parent qui veut ça il veut
pas essayer veux pas jouer au cow boys 3
il veut pas jouer un petit coup h3c 5 et
les noirs en reste à leur encontre aux
faibles mais sur don qui fait force 3
ans et plus en f3 donc il donne le pion
à deux lancers dangereux doit reculer le
fou dans le côté c'est malin c'est bien
vu que certains joueurs cavale est là et
en clair il faut qu'ils gardent un oeil
ici sur cette grande diagonale dont qui
quand même il maintient la pression sur
sur ce fameux pioncer 6 cet effet mais
est ce que là est ce que la chronique
peut pas jouer le coup libérateur
peut-être c'est assez simple non il y
aurait un fou prend un fou alors il faut
prendre ou d'un profond il faut prend
1,3 et maintenant fou prend à trois et
on voit que le pion ici est cloué
puisque derrière il y aurait le fou
emprise et donc le rien n'est résolu les
des problèmes il ya des gros problèmes
puisque la menace c'est tout simplement
plus on prend avec un flou et ça devient
très très difficile on pas augmenter la
pression partout peut-être même dame ces
deux faits et ça va on pourra maintenant
pouvoir
donc c'est normal il prend et puis en
plus il dort dit qu'il est bien voilà il
a bien pu prendre l'option tranquille
voilà c'est bien
prends h deux échecs toi c'est dans son
style quoi up et je reviens à la maison
j'ai pris mon pied maintenant à toi de
jouer
il démontre moi que tu peux faire
quelque chose et il peut je pense que
les compensations en fait c'était l'avis
général c'était que les compensations
sont suffisantes
hébergement qu'avait laissé 4 donc
attaque à la fois le fou et le plomb et
le pion alors imaginons par exemple que
les noirs face à un coup comme petit
rock
ce serait une erreur négligent très
négligents donc sans doute y aurait qu à
l epr en fout tout simplement dame prend
1,3 et on a une qualité il faut prendre
3 et derrière la dame ya la tour et donc
on prendrait ce qu'on appelle la qualité
on se retrouvait avec le cavalier contre
une tour entière tout toutes pièces
étant égales par ailleurs
eh bien ça serait gros avantage blanc
exactement les avantages décisifs
donc c'est pas possible donc il faut
enlever le fond voilà tout simplement et
en laye un coup donc il a joué le coup
logique que fo prend 1,3 oui mais en
laye à un coût très amusant qui était
discuté c'était tout repeindre tout
prend 1,3 donc on donnerait à tour alors
l'idée c'est surtout prend 1,3 ou alors
c'est ouais mais s'il n'y a pas foule
prend 1,3 justement c'est simple combler
avant la nature souvent à droite roi fou
prend 1,3 et laquelle il cette île et la
belle c'est toujours la même chose voilà
je n'empêche c'est très joli mais ton
prends ton printemps jouer simplement
petit rock et je pense que les noirs en
fait surtout par 1 3 ont fait pas cette
manoeuvre ont fait petit rock et là où
il peut jouer comme la partie tourasse
un petit rôle
bon c'est pas si mal en fait des changes
il faut de gaza voilà donc c'est
peut-être tourné en 3 5 points
mais comme il en est qui marche pas donc
faux prend à 3 petit rush sais pas je
t'aime on n'est pas morts on n'est pas
obligé de prendre des tirs croisés entre
le jeu de dames que tu voulais démarrer
en fait que j'ai les mains il cote a
démarré voilà j'ai appris à jouer de mon
grand-père a été grand père et parce que
de donner voilà c'est ça n'est pas de là
il ya une fois de plus dans ma dette
aime c'est sérieux je me rappelle très
bien
selon l'adage populaire les dames
ressemble beaucoup aux echets oui ces
gens qui savent jouer ni à l'un ni à
l'autre qui pensent nous ensemble des
fermiers ou un effectif c'est vrai que
ça ressemble quand on sait pas jouer
dans cette position c'est loin besoins
en fait le dernier ses dix fois dit oui
les chantiers c'est lui x 8
et en plus le damier se met 15 nord à
droite oui aussi s'il se met 15 morts à
droite et alors que le l'échiquier case
blanche a de plus en plus aux dames
enfin les pions sont tous ces mêmes
avaient pu rodern voilà il ya que deux
pièces des pions évidemment oui donc
voilà donc j'ai commencé à jouer aux
dames et puis parce que mon père
trouvait j'étais doué pour vous pour aux
dames oui donc et en fait j'ai été ravi
étaient ravis de t'accueillir d'ailleurs
on peut saluer un de tes amis dacquois
qui était restreint qui mène à tout à
fait bonjour pierre regarde donc pierre
t srec qui s'occupe de kyoto dax et qui
épie talata un peu servi de deux
professeurs de mentor en fin de semaine
et je ne soutiens et c'est quoi un ami
aussi deux des grands prix déchets qui a
un ami du grand prix des chèques de
l'émission de le guen a mis des échecs
quand j'ai tourné un grand ami des
échecs dans les échecs archi architecte
passionné
passionnant oui passionnant voilà alors
d'apartés comme ça sur joueur d'échecs
l'étrier très bon joueur d'échecs en
tout à fait mais on a pris une semaine
alors donc faut prendre un set
donc il faut reprendre il faut reprendre
logique et maintenant tour à saint vit
là on peut voir l'idée de topalov c'est
qu'il veut empêcher ses seins il veut
empêcher c'est ça ouais bien sûr
maintenant c'est vrai il ne fout quand
même il fait grise mine à 17,1 ce fou
est mort ce fonds est mort en tout cas
il est bien moins reluisant que celui ci
voilà c'est celle ci qui tape que sur
quelque chose et donc nous contre eux
jeu et là les compensations sont là
quand on sait qu'on sera moins largement
ses filiales qui ont moins clairement il
ya un mur - c'est celui ci la qualité
qualité prix là aimer c'est pas très
grave
c'est vraiment les compensations sens
mais peut-être le tenir le coup suivant
c'est ce qui va faire il va il va
justement bon et des gens très bientôt
rêve des victoires des doors l'idée
c'est de jouer sans doute tout de suite
après derrière on peut pas on pourra pas
prendre du plomb puisqu'il ya la dame
n'est rien
donc là topalov dit on sait jamais nous
n'aurons à et mélangez 1 c'est le projet
un et voilà c'est un échec
et maintenant il mène alors voilà il
veut pas il veut garder cette poubelle
qui lui empêche moi je m'en fous de
jouer
il veut simplement échanger les fous la
dame protégeant lucien évidemment
égalisé samedi qu'il veut pas nommer à
la tête
voilà il y a été noire sa stratégie sera
toujours la même c'est il veut le plus
solide possible à l'animation avec les
blancs aussi oui non mais j'ai tenu leur
approche du ouais c'est vrai un an mais
c'est clair ça c'est clair
et puis en plus sachant que topalov peut
prendre des risques inconsidérés s'il en
veine une autre je vais me battre
il risque en gagner d'autres oui mais
c'est un délit note ce match est plié
quelques coupures bien ça s'est déjà vu
de remonter deux points et fisher l'a
fait un nom mais je veux dire si il en
perd encore un serveur comme ça fait 3
ça fait bien c'est trop il ya eu ça il
ya eu ça dans un mode kasparov et karpov
oui il en coiffe à remonter trois points
qu'on sait pas pareil ouais enfin comme
ça que c'était pas l'aimer mind à
l'époque qu'est ce qu'on va faire peau
qu'il valait arriver un nombre de
victoires n'ont même c'était un match il
me semble que c'était un match non non
je n'étais pas celui-là c'était un autre
match où
au cap en a gagné trois de suite
d'accord non match à 24,1 des matchs en
24 imbsheim semble s'il fallait arriver
un certain nombre de victoires à
l'époque ce n'est pas cela sur ajouter
match de moscou 4.5 oui non mais là
parce que oui m'enfin je sais plus en
fait faudra vérifier mais enfin il me
semble que c'est l'image en tout cas
devrait beaucoup plus longtemps s
étaient pas tous partis en vérifiera
mardi jeudi à perdre trois parties le
match est plié tout à fait probablement
ya là bas un match beaucoup plus qu
d'ailleurs les matchs se raccourcissent
chaque fois parmi les spectateurs il y
en a sûrement qui disent mais quel
abruti raid avant que c'était vrai ou
pas je donne des surnoms mais ils
étaient menés 4 à 5 051 ya laissé les
5000 rester premier à 6 ça c'est sûr ça
c'est le match avant mais il me semble
que amour est donné dans un autre match
j'ai posté celui de séville justement
par exemple ou me semble que oui il y
avait 24 parties de ce parti wassat et
oui mais sans kiki qu'il était mené 3
points que la remontée d'un coup il a
remonté en trois parties bon santé
d'ailleurs ça avait tonné kasparov y
avait parlé de fuite il avait parlé de
plein de trucs comme ça il me semble
enfin à vérifier bon bref
alors en attendant en tout cas si plein
de partie c'est sûr ça c'est déjà très
belle murray s'est déjà très mal barré
tourcoing ces cinq unités de chroniques
cavaliers au quatrain très bien joué et
que c'est la protégée par le fou ici
tranquille et on bloque les quatre aussi
apprécié non échangées alors s'il avait
changé alors rien [ __ ]
trois breaks 3 dame prend trois points
le cavalier va venir à eux cinq puis
c'est 6 janvier
même si c'est pendant chose et dans son
petit peu mieux ouais quand même
avec une grosse pièce dans le camp
adverse voilà une grosse pression qui
peut être soutenu par des 4 b 4 des 5
voilà et c'est un deuxième programme
c'est un petit ami qui connaît
lily c'est que pour un fait souffrir de
nombreuses normes aux adversaires dans
ce genre de positions en doublant il
veut pas rentrer là-dedans il veut pas
être moins bien donc il joue cavalier
oklad très bien dit ok donc alors donc
forcé de la prise car les hauts cadres
donc issifou prend 1,4 alors pourquoi
forcer dungy l'horeca et c3 ici et là
car les c3 la dame doit bouger et le
répondra voilà il le foot en prise afin
de montrer comment c'est intéressant
donc sur tora cinq cavaliers s'éprend et
on voit que la dame ne peut pas rester à
défendre mais là exact donc par exemple
l attaque le cavalier il faut prague 3
les deux prix sont désagréables soit je
prends le cavalier mais j'ai bien aimé
le foot ça rien de problème le fou est
plus fort et si je prends l'avion et
bien c'est ça si je prends du pillon
évidemment je me casse le rock un laser
le roi est et tout marche comme ça alors
faut pas être trop prend 1,4 faut
prendre quatre dames g4 bon pratiquer le
foot tout simplement peut-être veut
mettre sa truie par la hausse humble
c'est une longue on entre dans une
période de longue manoeuvre ou bon on a
l'impression que tout paloffis lycée de
fatigue et ouais ouais c'est ça mais là
c'est vachement imagine physique
ah c'est sûr ça va sourire d'ailleurs
j'ai sur les nerfs il veut sa lèvre et
15 ans et la seconde chronique après dix
mois j'ai vu sa prédiction de match
inédite jusqu'à jusqu'à huitième partie
4 à mika et de dominer pour l'instant ça
se passe quand même bien c'est vrai mais
qu'à la fin il est laid craquer voilà
sous la pression de topalov c'est
possible parce que les partis quand même
bon même si le résultat n 13 en faveur
de chroniques les parties sont toujours
longues
ouais c'est pas comme aigle échos où il
ya quelques jours de repos il y avait
des nues leur vin coubon sur un nul
assez rapide là ça dure toujours plus de
coeur un coup oui le lâchera pas topalov
va pas laisser kramnik se reposer et
donc il nous fatigue donc ils jouent les
le jour sportif
je pense que le jeu d'échecs vu par
topalov parce qu'il a raison alors là je
fais entièrement mois pour cet état
d'esprit je pense qu'il sait un sport
donc la fatigue joue et je vais non
seulement je vais mettre évidemment une
pression chicken maximale mais je vais
aussi mettre une pression physique
maximale et jouer jusqu'au bout avant
est trouvé
les complications les plus longs le plus
longtemps possible qu'on peut penser que
cramique qui voit s'est préparé pendant
six mois très sérieusement au sein du
sport en arrêtant de fumer ça c'est sûr
ils ont été tués 11h10 paris sanofi n'a
jamais fumé de sa vie et ça fait dix ans
que du sport toute façon il les remet en
forme c'est arrivé je veux dire c'est un
truc c'est non mais je pense que c'est
pas le faire un six mois on peut pas
rattraper des années des années
d'entraînement je pose de ce côté-là
topalov apporte une nouveauté dans les
échecs qui n'ont weekes parfois été le
premier effectivement quand même mais
bon moi je les ai vues de mes méthodes
pas l'offre est encore l'année dernière
la coupe d'europe
vingt équipes tous les matins je me
réveiller un peu les j'allais à la
piscine comme ça et je voyais kasparov
qui avec deux quiz qui pratiquement une
aussi faire vibes et des allers-retours
dans la piscine et des pompes pendant
une heure à une heure et demie quoi tous
les matins et loyal et l'après midi
libre sa partie donc c'était quand même
c'est impressionnant oui voir les côtés
en énergie à l'après midi pour la partie
donc c'est vraiment kasparov qui
accueille ce week-end initié ce
mouvement là c'est mais on peut dire que
que topalov ya rajouté une prise de
risque sur l'échiquier
au delà de au delà de la normale quoi
oui c'est vrai parce que là la kasparov
était peut-être plus scientifique
s'était quand même moins
mais le côté sportif aux chiens on peut
vous le dire mais on peut dire topalov
empoli héritiers de fisher et kasparov
et chronique plutôt lé chili héritiers
de karpov on va dire un mais c'est vrai
dans le style ainsi on il faut se
rappeler de chroniques m je m'appelle de
thermique en 97-98 tibati qu'aspirant
faisant et cet épisode pièce où nous
inkoom
donc il faut il vraiment c'était il
faisait vraiment né il a changé de style
mais il aimerait vraiment un style pour
arriver au sommet en tout cas il arrive
un très beau style très beau style
travaux cible d'attaqués alors on va
voir la suite après d'alger quatre fous
des trois îles c'est vrai qu'au ci com
sa série d'un genre de position même si
fatigue chronique on voit pas trop
comment il va faire craquer car ni quoi
oui moi mais dans cette partie on verra
plus tard qu'il avait une chance et une
bonne chance de la voir mais
oui mais peut-être que là est peut-être
c'est sur la fin un jour voilà c'est ça
c'est faudra attendre la fin des
programmes enfin moi je crois aussi que
ça c'est la clé du match
moi je pense voilà depuis le début je
sais le match s'est terminé avant
c'est-à-dire leur faut partir voilà moi
je me suis dit ça va se jouer sur ce
terrain alors je sais pas qui va
l'emporter mais j'ai toujours passé
depuis les buts c'est la clé va se jouer
là c'est à dire sur la résistance
physique est ce que est ce que crâne il
va pouvoir tenir suffisamment est ce que
touba va pas perdre trop de points à
avec ses coloris their de prendre
position sur la fin ça mais bon s'il
prend pas de risque qui peut être
réussie peut pas lui mettre la pression
non plus donc l'un dans l'autre on verra
on verra qu'à la fin venir c'est
difficile de faire des pronostics
aujourd'hui alors tout va lancer sa
langue lisse des pronostics mais ça
s'est tout de suite je dirais moi je
n'en mets une question moi je pense que
quand j'arrive pas j'arrive pas à savoir
vraiment qui va gagner ce que ce qui est
sûr c'est que bon mais le maintien pour
être considéré comme le vrai champion du
monde 500 que son club problème alors
tour assez vite réagi qu'il va charger
être dangereux cette tour là qui est
quand même bien placé dans le camp
ennemi issue en voilà donc tour à cinq
ans il préfère donc double et en double
sur la traverse
donc ça c'est pas usuel le doublé sur la
cinquième mais oui mais il veut garder
cette non c'est ça qui est bien placé
une tête joué par là je ne sais pas il
veut la garder l'accord ils veulent bien
les garder qu'ils agissent très bien ces
cinq à être bien pour bébé il fait
tomber vite parce que le ces règles et
deux tours sont un peu se marche un peu
sur le dessus et il à table puis voilà
c'est tout on là ils attaquent le pion
environ d'amd ont donc repris et pour
protéger pions et attaquer le faut en
même temps donc je perds pas de temps qu
évidemment surtout prend ses cadres il
prendrait du temps mais pas comme la
lumière annick qui n'a pas voulu surfer
les plantes n'est sûr non mais là il
reprend des pions
dans le savant taj oui là c'est gros
avantage c'est faible
ici ces documents-là s'est offert une
très fort et cela est passé donc c'est
un gros avantage alors ta main après je
suis allé un peu trop vite d'amd
m'attaque le foufou et 4 il
m'impressionne tourner
voilà un guide et un petit piège dont
tour prend b3 en fait ça y est c'est pas
d'échangé et puis tant qu'on est trop il
y aurait cavaliers des deux cas il ya
deux attaques la troupe et le fourchette
clac clac fort qu un exacto donc ici
tour bessette protège le pion que je
protège avec la tour et la dame
donc je contrôle très bien attaques
adverses et la met la langue kabyle d2
dont jolie voix la très jolie très joli
c'est pas mal ça défend temps ça attaque
ça se contrôle bien les cases blanches
non c'est un coup il est bien centralisé
comme il ya un piège ici joli et un
pierji si je vous fous des cinq pour
attaquer le fou des cinq attaques le
pion berlin voit là un jour et aucun
quand même attaque le fou un tacle fou
et enlève des cases aux faux et auraient
envie de casseurs faut prendre 3 semble
logique
voilà cavale et prend le nom et la torah
on ferait pas qu'à les prendre non ils
iront est pas tombé huit cas parce que
le foie pas de case deux fois quatre
cases et de seulement et non premier il
a pas de cas ici il n'a pas casella ici
l'emprise de la tour ici l'emprise du
cavalier ici évidemment prise du pion
est ici emprise de la dame donc il a pas
de cas qu'il faut le protéger le protège
et maintenant on prendrait coup en mai
trois ont fait tomber trois jours et
trois tours en béton promet 3 qui prend
les trois temps prendrait trois là la
mauvaise nouvelle le fameux match du
couloir
pas mal du coup là mais bon il faudrait
et c'est fini et oui un piège est pas
mal un joli piège joli joli cadeau des
mains pour en venir c'est un piège c'est
vrai c'est un piège bien sûr ces mais
bon c'est la gamme pour le oui m'enfin
bon on a bien vu quand même que topalov
a raté un match mais dans la deuxième
je veux dire on avait surtout ce qu'ils
font c'est vladimir à mettre le feu sur
une diagonale qui est moins plaisante
que l'autre parce qu'on regarde la
précarité des deux alors après qu'harry
de le fonds ne peut pas rester sur la
grande diagonale h18 donc il peut pas
rester là du coup là il est en prise
donc il faut qu'il s'en aille
et oui et donc c'est une petite taille
est plus sur cette diagonale qui était
active vers l'europe qui est ici va pas
être actif ce qui contrôlent rien que du
vide mais que du vide alors fou g6 et
maintenant d'hommes ces trois là
tranquille donc joly bien vu topalov ce
surnom tout sur noir
donc il ya des retours c'est lui sur la
couleur inverse du fou donc qui lui ne
tape sur rien sur la seule les seules
pièces sur blanc c'est ce pion qui même
plus attaquable par le fond maintenant
et celui-là alors qu'ils aient pas pris
l'attaqué avant longtemps maintenant
aussi ce cavalier superbe puisqu'il
empêche toute remise en jeu du fond
c'est un très joli cavaliers c'est un
bien centralisée est au coeur de la
position de défense et n'ont ils pas
mais bon c'est vrai que les noirs encore
noblesse il ya eu un set
c'est un envie de le mettre là ce que
venez aussi mais bondées que lecavalier
pain le four vient comme on le verra
plus tard
alors à 6 très beaucoup h 6 h 6007 le
foudroiement le roi déjà il ya plus bas
du couloir des voix les plus demandés
collard tour à 6 ont écrit cote un peu
rond ça tricote tout faire il veut il
veut peut-être triplé tour assez si il
veut peut-être triplé mais pour faire
quoi pour aller changer une tour ou
venir ans et 7 mois mais changent les
tours c'est bien pour crown x ah oui
mais venir la tour 1 c'est cissé a
tendance à 7 et essayer de prendre
pioneer press et 7 et puis après c'est
titi espions quoi essayer de s'imposer
affaiblir la défense de ce pion
bref cette course est tranquille et
maintenant il a cependant bizarre
bizarre parce qu'il veut cavaliers à 5
mais il perdait au four via est le fou
peut revenir ici et
eq rami qui va pas s'en priver est ce
qu'il aurait pas pu essayer non f3
peut-être f3 damage 4e place et ça ça
fait migros les cases noires elles dame
vient h4 menace dès maintenant en main
ici pouf et toutes les cases noires sont
prises par la dame qui peut bien venir
faire des échecs perpétuelle ici donc
évidemment ça a pas l'air très bon temps
et je sens qu a laissé 4 x 4 affections
cardiaques atteint ses limites il aurait
pu revenir
une maintenant l'échangé d'idées oui
donc ça veut dire qu'il a persisté dans
son idée il ya quand même joué trois ans
il a joué oui et joseph iii mais oui
c'est dangereux je ne sais pas c'est pas
terrible c'est pas terrible
placer ses pas il est un peu saoul qui
n'a pas très bien géré cette période
aparté fou des cinq cavaliers des deux
protège bien le qi gong est renvoyé ici
d'enfermer le flambeau l'insee il le fou
est revenu sur une belle position
maintenant au tour des v8 pouf pouf pouf
humaines du coulin mais non plus ce
piège grosse pression quand même sur
pétrole donc dam des trois échecs
pouf ici c'est le coin où elf 5 tout
simplement donc f5 logique si j'ai six
flore qui par exemple où on n'aurait pas
pu remettre le roi tout simplement non
parce qu'il y aurait toujours cette
histoire de quatre sur quatre peut-être
derrière nancy on
minerois que se passe-t-il regarde on
imagine on rejette aucun atout il ya
aucun point 4 et surtout prend b3 on a
le même idée que tout à leur tour ces
trois tours autour à trois peut-être
tours 1-3 pour tour à trois et ça y est
oui un salon diatonique non non c'est la
sergic aux égéries tour ce serait bien
pour ces trois avec nous et en de
dominer toujours et toujours dans nos
vies foot emprise alors il reste des
matches 4 pour essayer de faire un
perpétuel avec la tour l'autre tout
revient maintenant défend tout
simplement plus de il ya plus de l'échec
puisque la principale et même ses plaies
mais situation toute leur vie maintenant
la dame et on est aussi et le fouillis
kaput
je vous aimais pas tout à fait pas tout
à fait puisque on peut jouer encore
dames et 6 1 l idée d un cas de prises
totales ici à la fin il y aurait dans
prend avec échec au roi et pouf où vous
ferez ce tour mais en fait tout
simplement qui est dit on à toi tout
simplement tour à trois et ça y est le
fouet prix fait d'une manière générale
on peut se rendre compte que c'est
dangereux précédent on veut pas faire
des choses comme ça l'était pas pris de
face et c'est compliqué voilà d'accord
donc alors jordan t3f 5 tout simplement
nos quêtes 5 à la fois donc on pêche
l'échec est aussi contrôler la caisse de
4 tout à fait ça peut être utile ça
empêche des 4 enfin ça n'empêche pas
tout à fait on peut quand même le jouer
mais
7 - est facile mais voilà pour ces trois
préfèrent défendre deux pions et landes
damas quatre là le fameux on a
maintenant qu'on a joué froid donc
signalé non mais l'un ici là les
commentateurs étaient d'avis de dire que
en l'espace de 4 5 ou chroniques a pris
l'ascendant
alors c'est rami qu'un petit peu mieux
ici adacore des gens évidemment quand ça
tricote sa tour il revient alors il
revient quand même c'est un aveu d'échec
tourin il revient bien sûr ça
il a reculé quand même pente au total
avant tout à fait d'alger 3 tu as mangé
trois dans mes chroniques joue pour
faire mieux donc dans ces deux donc là
maintenant ça tricote un toi dans ma
tête
t'aurais fin ils menacent aucun temps
ils menacent une menace
bah oui tu veux jouer avec la tour en c3
qui va tech lens est toujours dans l'air
à tous les coups il ya la dame ravin sur
un vis-à-vis du roi donc il ya des
échecs possible bon c'est jamais simple
alors investissent donc ça couvre déjà
dam des trois dames g3 tunisien bon
voilà bon ça tricote quand on avait
cette affaire vient même position bon
c'est nul je pense qu'elle que les noirs
qui peur d'essayer de presser mais le
problème c'est que ce options n'étant
pas l'homme qui va jouer et gagner tout
à l'heure je veux jouer le lâchera pas
même si besoin est les nouvelles règles
qui ont été utilisés en corse mais à
sofia oui c'est bon mais on joue
jusqu'au bout et c'est que l'arbitré qui
peut dire que c'est nul
voilà donc on peut pas et on va le
sentir à ça et je pense qu'il a raison
c'est pas plus mal et que la fatigue
physique doit jouer mais non même si
l'échec c'est pas que j'aime alors c'est
tout à fait une digression tout à fait
intéressante à la fin de ces deux dames
g5 more lie à ses patrons un tourin
dames et si l'on est créé plus ou moins
une menace f k un autre cadre
s'il n'englobe pas parce qu'il ya la dre
avec le roi c'est la droite ici adam
bouge mais qui ça tricotant mais ça
n'avance pas pourquoi pour 17 tours à 4
ils attendent l'erreur c'est maintenant
il tombait des huit tours ces cinq
projets lui voilà maintenant il peut
jouer pour eux 5 nov 2005
maintenant il peut jouer on voit très
bien de celle et nous arrive le roi
qu'il a quitté là où il est le leader
peuvent tenter de faire des choses au
sein des caves les c4 et voilà alors là
c'est le conte qui était critiqué fou
prince et 4 c'est énervant
ça c'est une erreur alors on va voir
tout kramnik avoue trouver lui faire nul
bon il aurait pu jouer n'importe quel
coût alors là topalov heinrich tour à
penser 4 voilà ça c'est aussi venir
c'est une erreur qu'il aurait fallu
prendre de la dernière de la dame avec
l'idée que ce pion est attaqué voilà
tout à fait donc leurs menaces tour à 6
tours se situe avec leur dernière
possession
donc il faut faire avec 4 c'était ça
l'idée de manière chronique ici ce qu'il
a dû encaisser tout aux cinq toros elle
attaque le pion et on voit qu'à le
clouage et le fameux cloud âgés donc
c'est dangereux
et là tu en prends toi tu en prends on
pourrait pas protéger ce pion aussi oui
mais à ce moment là ça a été un des 5 et
6 il ya eu un set qui traînent là espion
qui traîne bien sûr bien sûr donc donc
f4 donc non non non non retour 5% donc
des princes et 4 f4f 4 tours 5 taureaux
51.3 qui on prend 1,3 c'est la bonne
critique tout point de 6 donc là
maintenant je prends il faut que la dame
viennent en fait sinon la tourner
bougerait avec un échec énorme donc
cette loi est découvert très dangereux
tout comme six donc d'apprendre icade
d'apprendre et quatre conteneurs de
pardon merci à pardon pardon vont alors
oui parce que ce serait une erreur ce
serait une
or et mat alors donc d'un bref 72.3 tour
prend 2,3 oui voilà dame principal d'un
procès 4 les français qui ont pensé 4
tandis qu'elle sait très content des
quatre tours et maintenant tout reprend
1,7 tout reprend ses cartons conséquence
normale et à la fin de cette es16
triangle doublettes sur la septième avec
des échecs ici et des possibilités
maintien et réduit fait que l'aimant
encore des chances de sauver mais bon
c'est pas facile il faut jouer le g5
pour empêcher la prise est là dans ce
cas là il y aurait tout rejet cet échec
oi et fuite huit ont accès tous âges
cette menace vite
échec et mat donc le seul coup c'est
roger huit mois et maintenant on a gagné
un pion et voilà c'est très délicat pour
nous c'est pas facile à défendre il ya
quand même un pion de plus bon mais
c'est les finales de tours donc si on
échange d'une tour par une cellule d'un
exactement mais avec les deux tours
surtout à river sur la 7e il peut y
avoir des chances de maths
pas simple quand même pas simple pas
simple mais disons que les gens parlent
de rejouer
vous avez vu ça ils auraient joué et il
serait toujours en train de bien sûr ici
à stephen king jouet alors tourner
apprend c4 donc erreurs on avait envie
de le voir
f4 maintenant ils voient la plus aucune
chance de gagner pour ces six on va voir
quand même la fin les indications total
liquidation qui on prend 1,3 d'en
prendre trois quand on prend des cas
l'ambiance elle simplifie mais pas comme
on échange tout comme nos rivaux nous
tous reprendre 6 d'arâches 4 attention
attention crise là attention et bien sûr
qu'il ya des manières de maths ici
attention donc il faut faire les choses
tout échange et d'apprendre et 4
attention maintenant la dame ici on voit
est loué par la dame est la dernière
petite tentative quand même de palop qui
jusqu'au bout on rigole fighters suis
lassé il est terrible alors tour huit
échecs et l'idée évidemment mon seul
piège classique il faut pas tomber dans
là dedans si vous êtes
le débutant un peu amateur aux échecs
faut surtout pas prendre l'atome est
parce que si vous prenez la tour
évidemment vous oubliez votre dame rsa
c'est pas bon et même s'il avait joué
bref c'est aussi une erreur à cause de
taureaux cette voie là aux échecs on est
obligé de prendre donc il ya d'autres
solutions pour les ouvrages 7 est quand
même plus saif essayé roef 7 et sur walf
set la partie à l'encontre du manager
toro cet échec pour les jeunes ouais
reprenons là d'un mais on prend un pur à
et on se retrouvait un peu de blues à
oui on va prendre
celui-là voilà bien sûr il faut y ait eu
un set il a changé d'âme
maintenant il propose est née la cia ils
proposeront un nul parce que là là là
ses joueurs avaient changé quand des pur
beurre c'est au compte de ce que c'est
impossible mais même deux contre un
même de contrôle dans ces finales la
semaine a donc déjà alors de contrôle de
ses biens sinon une fois que c'est sur
un même élan général c'est délicat donc
belle partie quand même un combative
il allait partir qu'on va t'il donc sur
le serveur le match continue et qu' il
peut basculer il suffit que topalov marc
antoine et on verra on verra surtout pas
oublier qu'il n'ya plus cette histoire
davantage du champion sortant parce qu
on a 17 points qu'il sait pas qui est
champion sortant donc c'est le cas des
témoins il y aura des tie break en cas
d'égalité c'est plus pareil
elle était vrai que c'est vrai après
douze jours de après deux parties la de
tokyo fait quand même favori mais j'ai
entendu dire que trawick le saurai plus
parce que thomas a fait plus de gars
font partie rapide habile très bon en
partie rapide c'est vrai mais après il
sera très fatigué j'aurais toutes ses
chroniques
oui je pense que ramener dans son
internat après après ce match là il sera
épuisée je pense c'est normal en tout
cas très belle
très bonne quatrième partie donc le
match continue
ça va être chaud ça va être chaud ça va
être chaud alors justement jours devant
elle et blanc dit attention il se passe
des choses
oui tout à fait il se passe des choses
c'est à dire que topalov a lancé une
lettre ouverte sur internet qui accuse
cram ni de tri qui posent des questions
qui posent des questions en tout cas qui
lance une suspicion canne à sucre
indique est allé trois fois aux
toilettes c'est ça il dit 25 x 25 x
d'être cette pente on est emporté 25
photos lettres pendant la partie il
trouve pas ça normal c'est parce que
c'est un endroit qui n'est pas
surveillée
bon ça c'est dans le soleil a pas de
caméra c'est ça on n'y a pas de caméra
one en mai alors bon non mais là on a
l'impression qu'on revient à l'époque de
fisher spassky c'est à dire que là il ya
la parano qui s'empare du truc
ils menaient 2 0 est ce que c'est pas un
peu une tentative de déstabiliser
l'adversaire à ce qu'il me laisse
d'arrêter le match a été de ma psy op
art of noise d'arrêter le match
messieurs dames oui bon est-ce que c'est
sérieux ou pas j'en sais rien répond le
comité d'appel je sais pas ce qu'il ne
sait pas ce qu'il faut faire mais c'est
vrai que
bon je sais pas c'est un incident en
tout cas kramnik a déclaré je suis plus
intéressé par la coupe des champions par
la ligue des champions de football sa
partie par la cei beaucoup de problèmes
ça va là mais c'est un peu une façon de
se moquer de son adversaire donc c'est
très chaud de le renvoyer dans les
cordes en tout cas c'est chaud parce
qu'il ça commence à venir l'intimidation
extra extra échiquéenne et à la limite
on aime bien ça vous irait faire ouais
ça fait ça fait un peu bon ok je vais te
déstabiliser moi j'ai du retard pas le
droit d'aller aux toilettes mais moi je
préfère regarder la ligue des champions
en tout cas on sait ce qu'un autre qui
disait exactement c'est qu'il y avait
trois fois mais aux toilettes mais en
fait ils avaient sorti les rentrées et
sorties en date est alors en dix minutes
10 minutes il est sorti en granit
c'est vrai que ça va travailler la
comprendre
topalov c'est ça parle à tout le monde
il m'avait obligé des gaz ou jacent rien
qui serait peut avoir en kalmoukie monge
qu avec les skis mais parce qu'ils
mangent des rutabagas ou dernier il a
amené son cuisinier aussi l'année où il
a amené son cuisinier
enfin bon on sait jamais ce qui peut se
passer enfin tout car suite au prochain
épisode
évidemment contient su ce match
passionnant vraiment je crois que moi je
moi je suis à fond moi donc passer d'un
pour les échecs
à très bientôt pour la suite
de diagonale tv actualité et puis tous
vos revenus ou sur le site officiel de
final tv.com inscrivez vous sur la
newsletter et puis n'hésitez pas à nous
poser des questions par mail ou à réagir
à l'émission
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous écrire et ça me fait plaisir
y compris quand c'est des questions
techniques etc n'hésitez pas merci à
bientôt et merci à laurent merci
stéphane au revoir
oh